[Musique]
en contexte actuel les musiciens ne
pouvait pas trop se produire un célibat
autant confie t de ce temps pour leur
proposer les créations et ce challenge
on propose donc au compositeur
interprète un texte écrit par le bar où
y écrit sheldon ils doivent en composer
la musique enregistrée et musiques et
paroles walla walla et nous l'envoyer ce
format mp4 la qualité de
l'enregistrement le vin bien le texte
doit être ne doit pas être modifié
on doit le texte de la chanson doit être
gardée après on a aussi le la qualité de
la musique
soyez créatifs et puis amusez-vous
pourra prenez plaisir à mon bac et de la
musique on a en lui donne et l'athletic